nos preguntan cuántos litros de refresco
tenemos para la fiesta y también nos dan
esta información adicional
quiero animarlos a pausar este vídeo y
que piensen en qué información de la que
tenemos aquí necesitamos para responder
esta pregunta cuántos litros de refresco
tenemos para la fiesta
vamos a revisar esta información tendrán
20 personas a la fiesta en realidad esto
no importa para saber cuántos litros de
refresco tenemos entonces podemos
ignorar esto hemos comprado 5 botellas
de refresco para la fiesta esto parece
útil así que tenemos 5 botellas de
refresco 1
5 estas 5 botellas de refresco
representan la información que tenemos
aquí ahora si tan solo supiéramos cuánto
refresco tenemos en cada botella sería
útil vamos a ver la siguiente
información la fiesta durará tres horas
esto no tiene nada que ver con la
cantidad de refresco que tenemos cada
botella tiene dos litros de refresco
esto es interesante cada botella tiene
dos litros de refresco aquí tenemos dos
litros aquí dos litros dos litros dos
litros y dos litros ahora si queremos
saber la cantidad total de litros de
refresco que tenemos tenemos cinco
botellas y cada una tiene dos litros
entonces tenemos cinco por dos y cuál es
el resultado de esto bueno 5 por 2
es lo mismo que 2
más dos más dos más dos más dos estamos
sumando cinco veces el 2 así que lo voy
a escribir otra vez aquí 5 por 2 es
igual a 2 más 2 más 2 más 2 más 2 y esto
es igual a 2 468 10 5 por 2 es igual a
10 tenemos 10 litros de refresco para la
fiesta y aquí tenemos otra cosa
la semana pasada usamos 6 botellas de
refresco para un día de campo esto no es
importante para nuestra fiesta actual